Mesa Arizona's Police Chief is promising
changes in his department after new body
cam videos showed his officers attacking
an unarmed man during an arrest we warn
you this video is disturbing the
officers are seen punching the man
repeatedly before wrestling him to the
ground they say he refused to sit down
the Mesa Police Department has been
under scrutiny before for excessive
force Jamie yuccas is at police
headquarters in Mesa Jamie good morning
good morning the officers were
responding to a domestic disturbance
call when they encountered 33 year-old
Robert Johnson and his friend who's
accused of breaking into his
ex-girlfriend's apartment the video
shows what led up to the confrontation
and it's aftermath newly released police
body cam video show officers on the
upper floor of a Mesa apartment building
ordering Robert Johnson to sit down when
he apparently fails to comply the
officers move in three are seen punching
Johnson including several blows to the
head
surveillance video also shows an officer
kneeing him in the stomach
after being handcuffed Johnson can be
heard swearing at police Johnson's
attorney says it's a clear case of
excessive force he wasn't doing anything
wrong
they searched them they patted him down
and they went over to the wall and they
beat him up police say they acted only
after Johnson refused to cooperate in
their incident report one officer wrote
Johnson's body language looked like he
was preparing for a physical altercation
still mesas Police Chief is opening a
formal investigation and changing police
policy there's going to be a special
directive that says that we will not
strike somebody in the face or in the
head unless they are showing us active
aggression Mesa police department made
national headlines in the past over
excessive use of force officer Philip
Brailsford was acquitted last year of
second-degree murder charges in the
shooting of Daniel shaver body cam video
showed unarmed shaver crawling and
begging for his life then reaching
toward his pocket before
Brailsford shot him multiple times
Ramone Batista took over as mesas police
chief just last year he by the way moved
very quickly to release those videos
after a pastor showed them to him just
last week three police officers and a
sergeant are now on paid administrative
leave John Jamie thanks so disturbing